this just in footage of me the air base
were talking about
al assad air base in 2006
now i went there and got to know these
guys at that time
look a little younger hair's a little
darker but these are
our brave men and women that were under
fire tonight
here with reaction live from washington
senator lindsey graham the great states
of south carolina
uh you know senator a lot has changed
since the
the conflict with iraq and the conflict
with afghanistan just like vietnam
right it gets politicized in that town
you live in the swamp
and we send these kids to fight bleed
and die they fight they give their heart
and then we decide
uh never mind that has changed my
attitude
about any future conflicts and i believe
it's changed yours too
and the president's clear there's not
going to be long protracted conflicts
and our military mind is stronger than
ever
yeah well the first thing i want to do
is thank those who are serving in
uniform in the middle east
because you're the you're the virtual
wall between us and radical islam we can
build a wall along our southern border
to protect us there but you can't build
a wall
between us and radical islam you need
some of our people over there
working with others to keep these
bastards at bay so one
to the family members i have complete
confidence in president trump
and his team to protect your family
member and to protect our nation
this is the first president in the last
40 years who really understands the
iranians
this was an act of war sean by any
reasonable definition
the missiles were launched from iran at
targets inside of iraq housing u.s
military personnel the president has all
the authority needs under article 2 to
respond
and higher response is yet to be
determined but he has that
authority to respond it was an act of
war by a regime for the last
40 years it's been a cancer in the
mideast
when they say they want to destroy
israel they're not kidding
they're the largest state sponsor of
terrorism so the president has to do a
couple things tonight
what can i do to restore deterrence to
make sure this doesn't happen again
and he doesn't want regime change he
wants the behavior of the regime to
change in three areas
their ballistic missile program needs to
change that's a good example of tonight
they need to stop being the largest
state sponsor of terrorism
and we need a nuclear deal that does not
ensure them a pathway to a bomb like
obama
obama was kind but khan by the iranians
trump is not going to be conned by the
iranians
so his response tonight is to deal with
those three buckets
how do we get the the regime to change
your behavior
you know and by the way i want to give
you a lot of credit cause you talk about
these warriors that we that put
themselves in harm's way for us you've
been over to iraq and afghanistan how
many times
57 times 57 times that speaks volumes to
me
um you're right about something did the
iranians want regime change that will
have to come from the people of iran
we can't be about that business
attracted wars conflicts boots on the
ground americans knocking on doors
and getting blown up that that's got to
end um because
washington politicizes these wars right
here's my question
i agree with you this isn't about regime
change it's about a change in their
behavior
because the president in my view frankly
showed more restraint than i would have
when they shot down our drone
when they took those tankers hostage
when they attacked the saudis
they've been the number one state
sponsor of terror how many americans do
we now know
that uh solomoni in particular killed in
iraq
um this behavior will get a reaction
and that is just the way the world works
and if we don't react we're only
basically incentivizing more of it well
what have we learned that president
trump can go from zero to 60 pretty damn
fast
so he absorbed the drone saying well it
was just a drone
i don't want to kill iranians because i
said to put the ito in a box it was a
pretty smart move
they go after the largest oil field in
the world in saudi arabia disrupting oil
flow in oil prices
and the president held back i can tell
you i was with him when all this
happened
when they killed our contractor that
changed everything
america first means to me now more than
anything else
you killing an american you're going to
be the first one we come after
so these missiles did not kill an
american tonight i hope
but it's probably more good fortune than
it is intent the president is very
methodical in his thinking he's got one
of the best national security teams
that i've seen uh since i've been up
here but never lose sight that we're
dealing with religious nazis they really
mean it when they want to destroy israel
and kill all the jews i wonder if
they've been disrupting the mideast for
40 years it needs
to highlight this you know there may be
a mindset and i know we have the
benghazi democrats and the bribe
democrats uh 150 billion in cash another
currency
with no any place anytime inspections
and it expires in 10 years and you can
re-begin
restart your your nuclear program was
probably the one of the dumbest deals
ever but this is a very important point
the last century we lost 100 million
human souls
fascism nazism stalin the killing fields
mao over 100 million souls evil exists
this type of behavior i don't want
protracted wars and i don't want boots
on the ground and i would arg
you never do that again but when they
when you're dealing with a sick twisted
ideology that would strap bombs on
children
and tell them to go kill americans and
israelis
i don't see how you begin a negotiation
with at any level with that kind of
sick ugly evil mindset to you well
this regime is probably somewhere
between al baghdadi he's on a religious
quest to destroy the world and change it
to
some a certain form of radical islam and
kim jong-un but here's what the
president i think
understands about the iranians they're
never going to change until you make
them change for the last 40 years have
been wreaking havoc on the world
and you've got a new sheriff in town
here's what i think he's going to be
thinking about tonight
what do i need to do tomorrow or the
next day to get them
back into a deterrent mode so they'll
leave us alone
and how do i get them to change their
missile program
to get a better deal on their nuclear
program so they won't have a pathway to
a bomb
and what can i do to stop there being
the latest largest state sponsor of
terrorism
the price to be paid by the iranians has
to go up before they will change
and the president is not looking for
regime change but he is looking for
behavior changes
now the targets are they going to be
military targets are they going to be
the oral refineries
that you and i talk about let me say
tonight if you're watching television in
iran
i just got off the phone to the
president your fate is in your own hands
in terms of the regime's economic
viability
you continue this trap crap you're going
to wake up one day out of the oil
business
senator graham thank you for sharing
that conversation with the president
we appreciate you being with us as
always